700 kilometers from any Battlefield west
of leviv a Russian missile struck this
house while the family slept killing
five civilians some still buried by the
bricks
my sister called me and said that a
rocket hit or fell on my other sister's
house she said arhalia taras and
Vladimir were under the rubble they
still haven't found them we were hoping
that they're alive but they're not alive
Russia launched 81 missiles across a
sleeping Ukraine early on Thursday
hitting infrastructure and residential
buildings in 10 regions including Kiev
Ukraine's Air Force say they stopped
almost half of the missiles but six were
Hypersonic traveling up to eight
kilometers a second the type Ukraine
can't intercept
many homes were left without power and
the Japanese nuclear plant was off grid
for several hours before being
reconnected prompting a stark warning
from the international atomic energy
agency this is the largest nuclear power
station in Europe operating for the
sixth time under emergency diesel
generators what are we doing each time
we are rolling a dice
and if we allow this to continue time
after time then one day our luck will
run out
in Caston three people were killed
waiting for a bus
it is just 50 steps away from my house I
feel so sorry for Ariana she was such a
good girl and more people died
residents clear up that feel overwhelmed
by the destruction
they're destroying our city destroying
every day there is shelling every day
evening morning all the time and here
are the results of this shelling
everybody is in shock everybody is
afraid we have no words to describe it I
go to bed and I don't know if I will
wake up the next day
elsewhere in the East the battle for
bakmut is intensifying with the Russians
saying they now control the east of the
besiege city
the Ukrainian military though still
hanging on for now but Russia has
reminded Ukraine with this latest set of
strikes it has the ability to strike
anywhere Charlie Angela Al Jazeera